j'avais fait 50 m 100 m fou tiens
d'ailleurs en parlant d'infirmière tiens
Pascal et Delphine si vous n'aviez pas
été animatrice vous auriez fait quoi
dans la vie toi tu aurais fait quoi toi
je sais pas avocate allez j'aurais j tu
aurais fait un truc chiant quoi quoi
qu'il arrive en fait d'accord non mais
c'est bien non mais c'est ça tu voulais
qu'elle dise quoi je sais pas ouais
voilà oui Delphine vous auriez fait quoi
vous euh moi j'aurais fait vétérinaire
ou professeur des écoles ah pas mal Mo
professur des écoles elle c'est même pas
ce que l'aurait voulu faire ça elle est
ici elle est au hasard Delphine
vétérinaire aussi TR des chiens frère
tous les jours ton chien il est malade
non mais c'est lui toi tu aurais voulu
faire quoi toi plein de choses sanceuse
voleur professionnel CP CP j'ai
l'impression que tu avais plein de rêve
toi c'est vrai tu avais plein de Rê mais
j'en ai réalisé plein quand même c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal c'est pas mal à
chaque fois c'est des petits morceaux de
rêve tu aurais voulu faire quoi toi g
ver archéologue ah ouais bah vas-y bah
bar-toi va chercher des trucs hein je
peux te dire personne va trenir j'aurais
été tranquille avec les vieilles pierres
ouais ah ouais bah vieilles Pierr Daniel
revient demain et en parle en viill PI
la
gentillesse tu aurais fait quoi toi Hugo
d'ailleurs c'est c'est le retour du
gomano c'est une
saison tu tu veux ton
câlin comment vas- mon tu m'as menqué tu
m'as
menqu s bonadore toi aussi tu m'as
manqué vous m'avez tous manqué mais par
contre c'est vrai que les looks ont
vachement changé là je trouve ouais
ouais ouais déjà j'ai je suis au lycée
là j'ai les CPE ma maîtresse j'ai tout
ça les infirmières et tout je me sens
moi je suis resté dans le même style un
peu est très bonne pou est très bonne la
pou la pekou est pas mal B j'adore pou
pas mal du tout il est stylé he très tu
très beau j'grade tu vas voir ouais
alors j'ai j'ai j'ai ton c'est toujours
en on arrête pas de se croiser on veut
se parler on arrête pas de se croiser
bah ououis il a essayé deppeler hier je
sais moi je essayer de l'appeler hier
ouis ouais il va essayer de t'appeler
peut-être donne un rendezvous c'est plus
facile pour sin appelle là il appelle en
numéro masqué non là il peut pas là de
quoi il appelle en numéro masqué oui oui
il appelle en numéro masqué moi je sais
que quand j'ai numéro masqué je sais que
c'est lui bah ouais B moi quand j'ai
numéro masqué je sais que c'est ma mère
c'est ou ma mère ou lui donc maintenant
je sais que c'est lui je vais lui donner
mon téléphone comme ça il t'appellerera
avec mon téléphone très bien mon bébé
voilà bon ça va tu es content ouais
ouais nickel cont entre Géraldine et
Pascal de la j'aime bien cette cette
petite PL mal tu aurais fait quoi toi si
tu avais pas été ce que tu veux alors
moi j'aurais été Stuart bien aimé oua
ouais ouais ouais pas pilot mais Start
et ou gogo dancer gogo dancer ça aurait
pu être pas mal tu peux le faire en plus
hein ouais tu penses que je peux faire
les deux
B je vais tenter ma chance rayon aussi
voulait faire gogo
don il a juste fait
gogo il a fait gogo sans la danse en
fait voilà c'est tout non non mais c'est
vrai Géraldine ah moi 1000 rêv j'aurais
voulu être architecte ah ouais et bah
joueuse de tennis professionnel
Gabriella Sabatini ah ouais alors c'est
une vieille joueuse he Gabri oui moi je
suis vieille donc j'ai l'âge de
Gabriella Sabatini vous dit quoi B je
sais pas Serena Williams voilà ah ouais
ouais ouais être sur le central de
Roland Garros avec une foule qui
m'acclame et gagner et monter avec un
trophée comme ça ouais cool bah attends
on pe le faire ici he ouais mais bon ce
sera pas pareil bah écoute on peut
essayer de faire ce qu'on qu'on pe mais
vous vous avez l'habitude de gagner vous
gagnez des padle et tout vous êtes
célébré dans le monde entiir être fol
quoi gagner Roland Garos ça c'est aussi
c'est un de mes rêves ou bah ouais ah
oui mais et au padle gagner quoi alors
ce serait quoi le tournoi au paddle déjà
un pm000 déjà déjà je serai content
c'est l'équivalent d'un grand schlem non
c'est un master 1 ok bah c'est énorme
pas mal qu'est-ce qu'il voudrait lui
encore changé de lunett ouais c'est pas
mal he que qui change de lunette change
de ququette
oui moi j'aurais mettre soit disque
Jocky soit éleveur de chien ah ouais
ouais bah tu peux faire disque Jok
éleveur de chien tu mets de la musique
vasyav quand j'étais petit moi aussi ou
on m'a appelé David Grota à
[Applaudissements]
l'école il se flashelle beaucoup guume
ça va vous sinon non non ça va pas rigol
frè non ça va ça va ça va ça va ouais
c'est pas mal les lunettes comme ça
ouais c'est pas mal ouais c'est un
délire j'aime bien moncher j'aime bienim
euh libraire avocat styliste c'est bien
libraire libraire c'est g libire mais
quoi ben Libra ma petite librairie à moi
ça c'est libraire tout est chiant g tu
dis rien Gill sans rigoler ah tout est
chiant regardez là c'est terrible que je
dis je veux pas l' cabler elle s cape
tout seul vouer chercher des vieilles
pierres cher des vieilles pierres
regarde dans non c'est TR chouette comme
M alors ouais et et toi Jacques euh
danseur acteur ah c'est vrai que il
était danseur hein ouais il était
danseur danseur où bah chez chez
lui non non tu étais dans B les Français
de NANC on B les Français de Nan dans
classique dans classque ah ou Patric
Dupont rigol tu rends compte ou pas et
les mecs quand tu faisais des pont alors
là je je vais me faire engueuler par la
la production parce que j'ai pas de
photos mais je pourrais t'envoyer des
photos ah
ouis quand on a pas quelque chose on se
fait jamais engueuler par la prod c'est
logique pour nous hein non non mais tu
faisais des pointes et tout non alors
les hommes sont sur demi-pointe ah c'est
demi- ouais mais on pourrait pas lui
mettre la musique classique é non
surtout
pas si Delphine siphine alors attends je
vais te trouver des photos sin on s'en
fout des photos non mais non mais on
veut voir on veut voir si vous l' aidez
si dphine t'ide non non
nonz
allez-yineineine fais une présentation
z une
[Applaudissements]
semaine alors c'est quoi la première
position ou
alors comm
ça je t'invite à danser tu voilà là par
exemple tu fais un piqu est sur
pointe c'est pas tout à fait ça al je
sais pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est classique c'est première
second après il y a des petits sauts
après
les caméras sont là les caméras sont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là s'il vous plat on cal il est
semainé mainant
[Applaudissements]
du Moon ok donc on arrête tout ça
ok là ça Jack du moonl c'est bon ok
doncc car merci applaudissement pour
lui
onagin je suis
impressionné je suis impressionné bravo
dphine très bonne idée de l'avoir fait
danscer tu vois ou pas non mais c'est
vrai franchement céit ça ça va rester ça
le petit le petit saut là tu sais que
c'est très dur à faire ça mais ouais
grave moi je le fais maisé 30 ans ESS
qu'est-ce qu'il y a cétait il
retrouvé incroyable 16 ans et dem
bravoc
[Rires]
PT attendsends
c'est mais là il y a trop de il y a trop
de tu avais un distributeur de Cal dans
ou
[Applaudissements]
quoi ti vas-y il joue un seeven UP là
s'il te
plat LG jou à coca aussi joue à coca
joue à Pepsi frère non mais c'est
incroyable bravo JAC e Jacques
franchement ils ont retrouvé j' et ben
bravo Jacques franchement c'était un
très bon moment ça il pas plus dur he
que la danse c'est une école de la
rigueur ah non je vous assure c'est le à
la danse c'est ah mais je le sais à la
danse c'est le pétanque la box te dire
que quand tu rates le cochonnet tu es
comme ça non je te le dis bravo